l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fuori j oggi siamo tornati su
the world siamo l'episodio numero due
quindi non ci voglia di fare riepilogo
sono pigro andatevi a vedere l'altro
episodio
buona visione che tra l'altro non so
neanche dove stiamo andando lì preciso
perché anche se fuori da casa mia perché
non potevo uscire dalla porta principale
perché ci stavano quelli che traslocano
ok shin e hai messo di tempo che ne
diresti di farti un giretto con me in
carrozza ah ok proprio preso l'ho preso
si chiamano c'è non posso infilarlo
nella tana guarda che sono uno
scoiattolo mica una talpa
vediamo se riesco a prendere gli atleti
adesso che l'armadio e qua dentro
che devo forzarla funziona niente qua
non possiamo fare niente quindi andiamo
avanti
posso guardare sul retro del camion non
ci speravo nemmeno che fosse aperta ea
quello laggiù ladro
c'è un ladro in casa ma non è casa mia
che se ne frega io posso entrare nella
casa del st ladro prenderò un ladro io
ma mi hai visto bene vai nocenti noce
attacca hai bevuto si chiama c'è me lo
sta dicendo poi penso funzioni perché
sono non trovo l'utilità del del
registratore
se torno nella mia camera da letto e
registro la televisione in televisione
c'era la polizia
poi la faccio ascoltare al ladro teoria
teoria e madonna reagan sherlock
sherlock fenomeno 4 bikers registrazione
della rapina non la sentirà mai da così
lontano eva c dentro è come faccio per
l'us postal più al megafono del ceco
sicuro che il megafono però non è ieri
come di come fregar gliela devo usare
noche premio non credo che ne resterebbe
particolarmente impressionato essendo un
non vedente che ne seguì il cane
eccolo amen ma no povera notte ma povere
ma no come l'hanno ucciso ma no vabbè ma
era sto per distrarli interior preso
megafon c'è niente non c'è morta se l'è
mangiato carne megafono vai megafono con
la registratore perfetto
[Musica]
c'è un genio
fenomeno questo sto vedendo lo sapete ha
lasciato il piede di porco che mi serve
per scassinare la camion e tanto si è
lanciato dalla finestra mica è mai
proviamoci a sto punto raga portiamo la
saracinesca per fare la prima e più
realtà allora con le buone si ottiene
sempre tutto non c'è dov'è finito noce
laddove vi sta parlando
per un attimo avevo pensato al peggio
diverse ore dopo era ma voce qualcosa
che puzza non sono stato io dove diavolo
sono finiti quei 2 esko ma da
controllare
ok ma è tutto questo cosa abbiamo fatto
a destra non ho capito devo per forza
andare a controllare dove sono finiti
gli altri
va bene non sarà un po tardi a
incontrollato l'ora quel penn del capo
puoi stare tranquillo è rotto non
piaccio così pranzo
peccato che quel pendolo se fermo da
anni amica sbagliati volevo darle alla
spada pensate vabbè perfetto ora come
mediano di cosa devo fare immagino che
quando si distraggono e debba far
proprio su questo
perfetto il cazzo e metalli e bellissimo
per ora non sono stupiti di questo va
bene ma devo spostare le lancette
perfetto adesso è un casino a sono
usciti proprio si sono accorti che
restate ingemi regate i geni chapron ora
è stato fermo adesso è cambiato tutto
sommato non arrivare torno a dare
un'occhiata e basta madonna che palle
questo modo che si sono incastrati sti
maledetti di nuovo basta non so più
quale dove hanno giocato sapevo lo
sapevo
ora basta si passa alle cattive la
sveglia non ce l'ho più raga non posso
più fare niente usa megafono e quindi
colto sarà migliore volere il timer per
garantirci la via di fuga
se vuoi che casi non puoi fare zionata
vera salta la cucina rega salta tutto
[Applauso]
è il padre bellissima ecco il viaggio
torniamo al furgone leviamoci dai piedi
fa bene ho messo un tubo nel micro non
miopia call questo journal il evadere le
palle se becco kimi ha forzato il
furgone che poi se ci pensi il
protagonista non ha la forza di svitare
un pomello romaradio di forzare un
furgone pensione in pratica secondo
leggi ultraterrena e chi si macchia di
un peccato di sangue verrà condannato
alla dannazione eterna al sopraggiungere
della morte ma quello di ronald è stato
un incidente
non cambia nulla è un particolare
irrilevante l'unico modo per impedire
che accada è confessare il proprio
crimine a qualcuno entro 5 anni e di
preciso quanto tempo resta tre giorni
e tu ci pensi solo adesso non mi andava
di opprimerlo volevo lasciargli i suoi
spazi quindi a è diventata sera perfetto
[Musica]
è la seconda parte questa ha visto la
partita ce che avevo già visto c'è poi
non so se è cambiata la demo per questo
avevo già giocato all'inizio maledetti
marmocchi
è il ragazzino va tutto bene perché sta
parlando a ok di un po la caduta tia
forse mozzato la lingua no signore non
ha un po presto per mettersi in costume
sì certo per halloween
ovviamente ma vedi di non crearmi
problemi fin che resti qui in giro
intesi cioè non sono vestito però la
gente crede che io sia vestito da lui
c'è la scheletro per halloween
va bene ok diavolo sono finito beh nella
discarica non aver certo c'è un gorilla
col deathnote conosco l'indirizzo della
nuova casa di ronan il problema sarà
farci arrivare l'armadio comunque a
parte sto casino e quando iniziamo usa e
credo di immaginare che abbia le chiavi
c'è stata ma ricordo proprio quindi è il
ragazzino ti sei svegliato finalmente ma
le chiavi sono quelle che ha sul
ginocchio vero mica non mi ricorderò mai
come prenderla mandragora meno male che
non ce ne vi faccio che se non era un
casino acqua q bo buga buga buga bronzo
e raducan ostrega sì insomma assorta
gente immagina crash medico trovi una
maschera vasca dice ostrega non mi
ricordo era condire l'alcol ad un uomo
adulto
io ucciderei persino per una merendina
ok
devo prendere le chiavi lì quindi
sicuramente dove infilargli qualcosa nel
cocktail ma non mi ricordo cosa e non mi
ricordo quando ho preso un papillon
bene devo prendere cose a caso adesso io
viario di tom riddle sette libri e otto
film non ti hanno insegnato niente se mi
hanno insegnato che la mandragola danno
fastidio
avrei voluto vedere come te la saresti
cavata se questo or cracks fosse stato
un nokia 33 10
caro il mio potter e sarà un po scontata
ma è che sempre bella devo usare la cura
che mi ricordo anche che dovevo usare
però non mi ricordo come usarla
se volete fare è chiusa per avere le
chiavi devo semplicemente ad avvelenare
il cocktail del team te lo assicuro
plutonio che è un amico di antonio che
cosa mi serve del plutonio pila stilo
un'altra fila tutte file ho trovato
aprea portano a si aperta bene meglio
aspettare che faccia buio quando i
ragazzi si saranno travestiti a ok
ingiustamente aspetti proprio ma che
bello non devo fare altro nome molto più
tardi
un botto di roba ragazzi credo che
allena di sky che io abbia fatto tutto
almeno secondo un altro a prendere via
libera
posso andare cioè quella rimasto così
per tipo tre ore è una roba così
wow un party all'americana pila di
bicchieri prendine uno sicuramente
richiede lo posso prendere perfetto me
lo ricordavo anche questo stare qua
sopra questa cosa me la ricordo raga
questa ma ricorda shenron risuscita
crilin fi poco lo spiritoso ok sai una
specie di giostra karaoke o cosa sono un
carillon per la precisione tramandato di
generazione in generazione nella
famiglia imperiale cinese
potresti cantarmi qualcosa conosco un
pezzo che potrebbe piacerti guarda sia
lee dragon rea
[Musica]
ci ho sperato un pochettino che uscisse
la voce di giorgio vanni dio le tue doti
vocali ma in realtà sono più un tipo da
musica metal
non vorrei importunarla ma dava perché
l'azione vecchio parlo con te wirth uno
da un tono con solo ad una disquisizione
fra persone civili cosa ha ragione mi
sono lasciato prendere voti fortuna sta
davvero facendo la somma vero cucendo
hunter che non erano certo lo sto
lavorando ai ferri perché mai dovrebbe
voler fare una cosa del genere
produco eco indumenti che mi
commissionano diversi potenti
dell'abbigliamento la lascio alla sua
impegnatissima vita lo porto nel mio
dimora sarò sempre aperto per te anche
perché non ha una porta e cs buona la
barbati quale non potevo fare niente
quindi fuori
entriamo la festa che non mi ricordo
assolutamente sazia
è successo qua o al bene cosa vuoi
perché sei così arrabbiato sopra è
chiuso e non possiamo fare un pazzo con
la mia ragazza biondina sopra
date le circostanze mi presterò da
interprete la camera al piano di sopra e
chiusa dunque io e la mia ragazza non
possiamo appartarci per amoreggiare un
po come mai la porta a casa e tv e lo
stupido johnny biondo sto con la
morettina sciacquata quello stupido
biondo di johnny si è chiusa in camera
con la morettina di facili costumi deve
essere piuttosto famosa da queste parti
perché vista tradita faccenda già
possiedono un'arma gli ha risposto alta
visto che non puoi andare di sopra
perché non mi dai una mano a portare qui
un armadio dalla discarica
vai al diavolo negazione piccata e si
trovasse un modo per liberare la stanza
d'accordo mi vedo pressoché obbligato ad
accettare vale ok non muoverti di qua e
non abusare di lei fino al mio ritorno
lo legge niente
ecco bravo non bussare con la cosa più
triste che abbia mai sentito le eletto
in tutta la mia vita a dio 28 giorno 6
ore 48 minuti 12 seconda quando il mondo
finirà donnie franco senti a me non mi
ricordavo niente regala veramente
quest'altra rompe dove sono qui
daft punk tu credi dei viaggi nel tempo
non saprei le a marisa voce gare
sembrano tutte fesserie è sbloccato e
questo sulla mappa ci si vede
coniglietta di playboy
ci si vede no no casa mia se ha segnato
sulla mappa che non tanto lettera
d'amore non l'ho neanche letto ti amo
perdonami ma non riesco ad avere
iniziare questa lettera di essere da
così sei tutto per me lo sai
da sempre dal primo momento che
incrociato lo sguardo
so che sarà così per sempre ed è per
questo che non voglio passare una sigla
latte ancora senza saperci legati
indissolubilmente l'uno all'altro
sposami spiega masegno sarebbe utile
possiamo dare da martin garics quasi dj
complimenti bella musica
non credo che riesca a sentirmi bene il
bicchiere rabbit è permesso solo per
capire ok gesù agio a proprio sta
giocando con giuda vie pong vecchia ci
sono quanta roba quanto così interagire
qua dentro gli anni fa riprendere bene
frigo tra l'altro
me lo ricordavo che potevo prenderlo
quello però non mi ricordavo cosa ci
fosse dentro il frigo peperoncino
effetto va bè ragazzi in tre vole la
porta
questa in fondo che lui abbia quindi
ragazzi questa è la seconda episodio di
the wardrobe spero vi sia piaciuto ma a
me piace un bordello è un casino che ci
sono un miliardo di robe da scoprire
però è figo veramente figo
spero che stia piacendo anche a voi
ragazzi comunque concluso per l'episodio
cose su youtube ultimi cercate e noi ci
vediamo sono prodotte dal comando non
chiudo al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]